foreign
[Music]
we're still trying to gather information
about what happened and we just don't
have conclusive evidence one way or the
other I know there's lots of questions
but we just don't have conclusive
evidence
one thing I can tell you for certain is
that the United States was not involved
in this incident in any way contrary to
Mr peskov's lies that's what they are
just lies so we're still looking at this
we don't have we haven't come to any uh
conclusions one way or the other uh
we're going to try to learn more but
let's not label it a report or an
investigation or anything like that
we're doing the best we can to try to
find out what happened we're still
trying to ascertain exactly what
happened here and do the best we can and
we're going to be humble about this
Jeremy there it may be that we'll never
fully understand exactly what happened
here I mean I'm not aware of any private
conversations between us and Russian
officials over this alleged drone attack
I mean it just happened yesterday
but I mean I I think we've been pretty
clear that what Mr pescoff says is just
a blatant ball why